[Music]
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ] ever
the wait is over
[Music]
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
in the drawer but i know enough
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough you're still blowing people up as
if life's not hard enough this guy's one
badass dude
[Music]
oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat
snake venomous
[Applause]
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in the mma i told aaron it was a
lightweight
[Music]
what's the worst that could happen
[Music]
you said it wasn't going to feel like
anything
[Music]
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
a bunch of nasa scientists right now can
i get a cold drink
[Music]
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie i made you another one
it's got to be over dude i think we're
all the way finished we're through
stick a fork in it
[Music]
you